c'est à cause de ce clocher que l'église
saint-pierre de plaisir fait peau neuve
à plus de 700 ans
cette partie de l'édifice n'était plus
assez stable et écraser progressivement
les structures de l'église aujourd'hui
trop vétustes pour accueillir la
communauté paroissiale plaisir oise
il était nécessaire d'accompagner ce
travail de stricte conservation d'un
travail de refonte complète de
l'utilisation d'église puisque le fait
que le coeur était instable et dangereux
faisait qu'on n'utilisait plus que la
nef de l'église donc la surface utilisa
pour le culte est encore réduit de
moitié par rapport aux dispositions
d'origine
la communauté catholique de plaisir a
donc lancé une souscription de dons pour
participer aux travaux
au 31 octobre plus de quarante quatre
mille euros avaient été collectés
peu importe le montant les habitants
sont attachés à leur patrimoine inscrit
au titre des monuments historiques
depuis 1947 dans cette église j'ai fait
le fils j'étais enfant de choeur quand
j'avais une dizaine d'années j'ai servi
la messe dans cette église est donc pour
moi c'est plein de souvenirs d'enfant un
chantier rendue difficile car sous la
dalle de l'église se trouvent des
centaines de sépulture cela implique un
important travail archéologique de
fouilles et d' analyses scientifiques
enfin côté finances cette seconde
jeunesse s'élève à 5 millions d'euros
les travaux devraient être terminés
avant noël 2013